hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday May 13th 2019 what's going
on and as the kids say how they don't
say that what do they see what's
crack-a-lackin' sorry is there anything
worse than when an old white guy tries
to sound like a young white guy trying
to sound like a black guy is there
anything worse bill I think there's a
lot worse if you pay attention to the
news that's my point that's my [ __ ]
point Pat al bad Al I'm playing I'm
playing I'm broken tonight at the
goddamn Comedy Jam Pantera song and mean
[ __ ] Josh Adam iers
that [ __ ] song it fits in with a lot
of [ __ ] that you want to say you know
like how we came up with playing that
song was he was going to he was talking
about he goes I got this tour going up
for the troops I'm gonna be hearing me
here gonna be there and then he was
trying to say Abu Dhabi and we was
[ __ ] it up and then we figured out
how to say it and I would been listening
to that I'm broken song so we won't Abba
Dabba doo-wah ba da ba ba da ba dee doo
right and then it just continued on wait
tonight I'm at the downtown comedy club
downtown comedy club downtown that's a
comedy club up downtown
sorry if you don't know the [ __ ] song
you're probably like what are you
talking about right now well you know
[ __ ] you alright I'm entitled to have a
little [ __ ] left here and every once
in a while I have this weird thing when
I'm really in a great mood it's really
early I'm knocking this out I'm in a
fantastic mood but at the same time I
think I got bit by a [ __ ] pack of
spiders or something through my left
foot is as red as my [ __ ] beard
they got me there they got me in the
back of my my thigh my left thigh [ __ ]
up my right side then the inside of my
old yet shapely left biceps and then
they got me on the [ __ ] right arm
oh my god and it's one of those things
where just it's just this 30% level of
itching and you try to ignore it and you
try to ignore it and then when you give
in ah it's ecstasy for like three
seconds and then whatever you scratch it
it just goes on fire and then you just
gotta lay there ah that's what I'm doing
you know I didn't want to wake up my
wife so you know I think technically I
think technically it's still Mother's
Day shout out to all the strong
independent moms out there you know
holding it down or whatever the [ __ ]
they say you know what I mean I had a
great Mother's Day yesterday I did I
went out you know my wife was like I
want a lot of flowers I want flowers
just a bunch of flowers that's what I
want and in my head I'm like you have to
stop watching the Kardashians did you
understand that they had they have
people honey
okay this there's like it's a set all
right and they buy a thousand dollars
with the flowers in the second it's
[ __ ] over they all get $5,000 for
promoting that flower company and then
they take that flower thing and they
take it down in the hospital and they
surprise one patient with dysentery
right hopefully they're not
claustrophobic cuz the amount of flowers
they have it's really just gonna bear
fill up the guy's room all right so you
know what I went out and I got the
flowers I'm a truck I was like I'm not
going out and getting a million [ __ ]
flowers by the way I was on the other
side of the world [ __ ] five six days
ago right so here I am now I'm gonna
[ __ ] flower shop and they're like we
do for you said what do you mean what
can you do his [ __ ] Mother's Day on
Sunday you know what you can do for me
help me
give me an arrangement there sweetie um
a couple of bouquets right bouquet
bouquet I don't want the [ __ ] it is
vases the whole [ __ ] thing so now
it's like I can't bring them in and I
got him in the trunk of the [ __ ] cab
you know I go over to the [ __ ] Rite
Aid which you know three for two days
before Mother's Day is
[ __ ] wrong gate over there when you're
trying to find a fresh [ __ ] card
every cards been picked up sniffle Don
[ __ ] red none of them in there are in
the right area so you can't find an
envelope to fit the [ __ ] card I swear
to God if I ran a goddamn drugstore two
things I would do one every night I'd
have some pimple-faced kid get over to
the cards and get it back where they
[ __ ] belong all right
I might even hire a [ __ ] 80 year old
security guard just to watch people with
the cards just so you could be like hey
you can't put it back in the right place
and then then I would get some [ __ ]
ice cream that's of a higher level for
these [ __ ] cute old people that
always come in there you know what I
mean
I always come in there and they got
their disposable phones that they
finally filled up they come in there
trying to get the film developed and it
just doesn't exist anymore and as their
little cute you know Greatest Generation
bottom lip starts [ __ ] quiver and you
hit them up with some ice cream some
good ice cream not that [ __ ] that has
the sandy aftertaste like they have
there is anything cuter than when you're
in a one of those typical long [ __ ]
lines at a drugstore Duane Reade CVS
Rite Aid cuz you they they run a [ __ ]
skeleton crew you know there's always
like there's like there's [ __ ] like
nine registers and there's always like
one person up there it's like what are
the other ones for just [ __ ] just like
back in the day when you'd go see a band
and they just have a wall of Marshall
stacks and only one of them was on the
others are just cabinets didn't even
[ __ ] anything in them
that's might they don't even I think out
of the [ __ ] eight cash registers at a
drugstore alright I think only like
three of them work I love when there's a
super [ __ ] long line and one of the
cashiers like gets the [ __ ]
assistants up here are the [ __ ] line
please
right and you like good somebody's gonna
come up here and [ __ ] get on it and
you're just the most lethargic like a
toddler when when the kid doesn't want
to go to bed just comes [ __ ] walking
up no sense of urgency
no nothing and you just like you know it
you [ __ ] suck one of the one of the
worst [ __ ] things that you can do is
is hate your job and then make other
people pay for it it's not my [ __ ]
fault this is where your life is right
now geez you know I learned that as a
comedian it's not my fault only five
[ __ ] people showed up so now I'm
gonna lean on the mic stand and not even
[ __ ] try I'm gonna give you five
people a [ __ ] chair all right it's
called being a professional fail these
[ __ ] [ __ ] they're all on [ __ ]
Instagram so you know all this [ __ ] all
this [ __ ] workout stuff and you know
work out goals relationship goals and
all of that [ __ ] you [ __ ] idiots man
how the [ __ ] you gonna get to that if
you can't handle the most basic job you
don't even have to punch in the numbers
anymore you just hold them in front of a
scanner it's so [ __ ] easy they're
teaching the customers how to do your
goddamn job uh don't get me by the way
[ __ ] New York City's airports I'm gonna
need a Thanksgiving dinner before I
[ __ ] go to the airport out there from
here on out every goddamn [ __ ] place
you go I got I got a banana and I got to
figure out how [ __ ] to scan a banana
then there's people behind the counter
they're not even looking at you I was so
[ __ ] pissed I went to like four
[ __ ] places and everyone had one of
those self checkout things and I'm a
little embarrassed that I did this so
[ __ ] mad you know I've been working
on my temper though this is like [ __ ]
ridiculous and I [ __ ] squeeze the
banana you know and if you watch the
Discovery Channel you'll see no more
animals on a whatever animal planet
National Geographic the white trash
Channel when you're looking at animals
right and you know some gorilla could
have ate that [ __ ] thing the other
night my lovely wife put on this nature
show right she goes you should watch
this this is amazing and we were
watching it was amazing it's like I
can't watch these [ __ ] shows because
inevitably it comes to the unbelievably
[ __ ]
on the ground depression of what we've
done to nature and what the [ __ ] is
coming you know do you realize how
[ __ ] pathetic and ridiculous it is
that were actually giving news time to
people getting offended by stand-up
comedy jokes
he said that joke at a show I wasn't at
I was offended really well losing like
[ __ ] half the [ __ ] rainforest it
seems like every goddamn [ __ ] year it
gets halved again or whatever you know
what is your problem I'm really waiting
for that day the day somebody on the
corporate end just stands up to these
[ __ ] idiots anyway so we were
watching this one this one thing about
this [ __ ] Birdman and it's hilarious
like these birds they gotta like they
got a deal he they always got it the
birds are big into showing off you know
I think the female birds I think birds
in general they're very shallow they're
like the [ __ ] Jersey Shore growing up
gaudy of the animal kingdom his birds
because so much of that [ __ ] is like the
male's food you [ __ ] puff out that
chest oh look at my [ __ ] colors over
here and then like the birds are sitting
there oh my God look at that one I bet
he's packets the [ __ ] needle with it
right so anyway they got this one bird
this black bird the [ __ ] thing first
of all it tidies up its whole area in
the force when I say tidy up I mean not
a twig not a [ __ ] branch it was
immaculate I remember looking at I was
watching that thing like I could [ __ ]
live with that bird alright because one
of the big things I hate it when I was
when I was a single man was living with
other guys like that I never I never
understood that whole there were guys go
to pizza crusts in the cushion pick it
up do the [ __ ] dishes [ __ ] animal
I mean I swear to God if you're [ __ ]
single guy right now I [ __ ] prided
myself on that some woman came over my
clothes
folded they were [ __ ] ironed the
place smelled good it looked good
wow what do you have a service no now
get over here and undo my 501 blues
sorry was a long time ago
501 blues we're all the [ __ ] rage a
long time ago oh wait a minute I think
my foot is it's not as red as it was
yesterday red Deborah Red Dead
Redemption
anyway the [ __ ] am i talking about
talking about all the birds so this bird
cleans up the whole area in the forest
all right and then when I tell you this
[ __ ] thing put on a [ __ ] Soul
Train [ __ ] I don't know what you'd
call it listen this [ __ ] bird was
watch I like it would it could make all
these different shapes I've never seen
anything like it if like it started off
it like put both of its wings like up up
in front of it said Nia swear to God it
took like a big like inhale in exhale
before it started like like okay gotta
get some [ __ ] right and it [ __ ]
brings it's it's it's both its wings up
in front of its face like a vampire and
then it just slams the wings down and
[ __ ] puffs up its chest like it was
in like ever look like I'm dance moving
like that Rhythm Nation Janet Jackson
video alright the bro is like I miss you
much oh I miss you much rather this
[ __ ] thing you can't believe and it
was spinning around I got to find out I
got I have to find this [ __ ] clip and
then in the end right and then the
female birds looking down like oh my god
look at him he's like the best [ __ ]
dancer right and the [ __ ] thing is
spinning around from looking down which
she was it looked like a top and the
thing kept stopping and doing like it
was like pop locking and think they was
[ __ ] unbelievable then in the end it
said for like the crescendo it started
you had like this dis yellow in its
chest or something and it would be
spinning and then puff out and flash it
just for a second though gave her a
glimpse big to yell
spots like that [ __ ] ring Kobe bought
his wife right after that road trip
playing the Nuggets and then the finally
the birds like oh my god don't judge me
but I gotta [ __ ] that right and after
this [ __ ] like Tony Manero was that
his name and [ __ ] stayin alive
Vinnie [ __ ] Barbarino goddamn dance
she's finally like alright your were
that you banging me and this thing flies
up behind her doggy style as a bird and
proceeds to [ __ ] this thing for about I
think maybe the thing two strokes and it
was done after all of this [ __ ] dance
it was like bang bang done you know I
don't know I got to admit it looked a
little date rapey like all of a sudden
she was over the apartment he was like
this is this is a let's put on some
[ __ ] music and then all of a sudden
it's Christ and it was over birds gonna
get me toad check it out if you can now
that's a fun part to watch but the rest
of it is you know I don't know there's
just there's something people who do
[ __ ] to kids women and animals like I
don't they that are you should just be
taken out you should just be removed
from general population
and people who [ __ ] walk half assed
up to a goddamn register at a [ __ ]
Rite Aid there's there's nobody there's
nobody there nobody [ __ ] there
[ __ ] 9,000 people trying to buy
Mother's Day cards and then people in
the back trying to get a refill on their
[ __ ] oxy that's what a thing is right
and then some old person so drug stories
and an old person trying to develop
their film downtown comedy club alright
what else what else are we gonna move on
to oh so the Mother's Day after I had
the flowers I had the flowers and
everything all set up right I had some
in the kitchen I had some in the living
room and then I had a I had a vow
and a vase full of some roses now my
wife does not like red roses alright
okay she's gonna do you little bird
dance and try to woo her right yeah they
got all different colored roses now red
roses are like the white people of
flowers well they were getting all the
work and now they're being a little more
diverse with the roses they got some
yellow ones I'm not gonna [ __ ] make
the joke there so anyways I got some
[ __ ] I got the flowers then I got a
card from my daughter
my lovely daughter to my wife so then I
had it all planned out all right let
mother bear sleep make her some waffles
and the bacon and all of that [ __ ] right
so I get my daughter up and she says
what she always says when she comes in
and she sees the best dad in the world
you know what she says to me every
morning she says I want to see mama
[Laughter]
Jesus Christ anyway the mothers they
just had the mothers have that it factor
I'll tell you right now you know if
you're pregnant right now with your
first [ __ ] kid as a guy you wait you
wait T what you won't you see with with
your your wife girlfriend whatever your
[ __ ] situation is like it's it's such
a beautiful thing
watching the person you with become a
mom it's amazing so anyway we have her I
ever walked down the hall that's how
much I'm crushing it with the card that
I wrote like the way she talks and then
I gave her one of the roses she knocked
on the door filmed the whole thing and
she came in gave her the rose gave her
the card big smile for my wife crushing
the whole thing then I then I just took
my lovely daughter for the basically the
whole day so she could just [ __ ] do
whatever took it down you know they got
this place we can like ride horses and
stuff like that
took her to the playground went up and
down the slide we ran around right
chased her I did all that stuff and uh
oh I forgot to tell my wife some boy
[ __ ] hit my daughter yesterday on the
jungle gym or whatever you call it you
know just hit him and there was that
this dad was [ __ ] Australia you know
he was just like I can't I can't do this
that's it no I Shaw I can't I can't do a
[ __ ] Australian accent not at 5:30 in
the morning
he's like say you're sorry say you sir I
didn't even give a [ __ ] it was it wasn't
you know it was a love tap it wasn't
that hard but the kid my daughter was
walking up to go play with something
they have all these like things on the
it's like a giant I don't know it looks
like a ship and it also looks like a
tree fort I don't know what the [ __ ] it
is this hallways and slides and things
to climb on it's a whole other level
from like you know when I was a kid you
just had the jungle gym which was just
metal bars and if you were lucky there
was sand underneath it you know I seem
to remember there was like that probably
wasn't tar they weren't that dumb but
anyway she ran up to this thing you know
you pretend like you're steering a ship
or something then the kid just came up
and just like boxed her up like great
form you know got the but pushed her out
and started playing and I hear this
Australian guy going you know all cry he
put another shrimp on the barbie and let
that [ __ ] kid kick was their first
right and the kid and my kid was just
standing there but I guess she was
infringing on his space she she'd turn
around and gave me he gave her a
backhand to the belly and that's one of
those times where as it as a dad you got
to do the judgment call and I was like
all right that's kids being kids let's
see how this plays out
and she kind of looked down her belly
and then she looked at him put her
eyebrows down and I mean it wasn't a big
deal and the other dad stepped in quick
enough it's like when a ref gets in NHL
fight before it becomes a fight becomes
two minutes for roughing for both people
and the whole crowd boos like nothing
ended up happening so I just kind of let
it go
and she's not old enough you know for me
to explain selfish [ __ ] and how not
to take [ __ ] from people but believe me
believe you me that [ __ ] conversation
is coming the conversation is definitely
[ __ ] coming at some point that's one
of the what's one of the sad things
about sending your kid around with other
kids is what they'll do is they'll
they'll they'll take a little bit of
your light you know especially if they
see you doing something or whatever or
they'll just be [ __ ] mean and selfish
and I think that's something I don't
know they don't they just teach you
[ __ ] numbers and letters and all of
that crap they don't add they don't
teach out how to deal with [ __ ] like
you don't need to take that [ __ ] you
know I'm telling you why I'm working on
my wife right now but I'm gonna get my
daughter when she gets bigger I'm gonna
get her into I think the Gracie's are
somebody out here one of those legendary
fight families they actually teach a
anti-bullying class and it teaches kids
how to defend themselves and it also
teaches kids when they learn these
skills to not go and bully kids and to
stick up for the other kids I'm gonna
get her into that [ __ ] cuz I saw a thing
you know there was this woman she was
taking she was taking this this doing
this bikini shoot in a park you know and
she was in the middle of the shoot and
she looked over and there was some guys
standing there masturbating right now
obviously the guy is wrong but you know
what every you know basically I'll just
get to the whole [ __ ] thing here
right so she's like she was shocked
she's like could you please stop doing
it and the guy was like go come on you
know you like it and then she just
snapped that she had trained in MMA and
she beat the [ __ ] out of the guy right
and now he's arrested and he's trying to
say I was just going to the bathroom oh
yeah well you're gonna piss in your face
what the [ __ ] was you dick doing you
dick didn't get the memo there buddy so
anyway that's obviously that's a great
story and I mean there's nothing
better than when a woman beats the [ __ ]
out of a pervert that [ __ ] you know
was being a pervert right but haven't
said that if you look at the bathing
suit she had on it was just like her
whole ass was out you know your whole
ass is out and you're in a park what is
in a park huh trees birds muggers and
creeps do you know what I mean what the
[ __ ] are you doing going into a park
with your whole ass out I don't I don't
[ __ ] understand there was just
something [ __ ] hilarious about I was
like could you not jerk off to me while
I take these pictures that guys are
gonna jerk off to when they get the
magazine or get put online whatever the
[ __ ] they do now I don't know that's
what I think then you need like old
school parenting like if ours our dad
I'd be like hey man that's great that's
great you handled your business with
that guy you know hey not for nothing
you know
next time you wear a bathing suit like
that why don't you just do it at a
friend's house in the backyard instead
of going to a park which is ground zero
like I think
Central Park in New York City I can't
imagine the streak that they're on that
somebody for like at all moments during
the day including at night there's
somebody in that park jerking off
without a [ __ ] doubt and then you're
gonna [ __ ] go in there living your
truth with your whole ass up you know
back in the day if like you had a
bathing suit you couldn't even show like
your knee and now people come out like
I'd say these Larry Bird's I'm talking
the guys to the Larry Bird short shorts
are coming back I saw a guy with the
short shorts on no shirt and just
sneakers jog by me and I just started
laughing I was like Nia that guy is like
98% naked it just became like to become
this thing where as long as you cover
your ass not even your ass crap all you
got to do is cover your vag or your dick
and balls and I want to be enclosed
cases any hermaphrodites in your vag
dick and balls you can't tell me if
somebody's our hermaphrodite right and
they got a big enough dick that they
don't try to push it into their own
[ __ ] they they have to do it right why
you there's no [ __ ] way
all right with that let's [ __ ] do
some after well I'm frustrating would
that be right and then as you dick
started getting hard it would then let
me want to stand up and go away from
your vagina and then you just be like
lord when does this torture end all
right there you go there's that okay all
right what the what is is this supposed
to be manscape it says mask ape mas
c.a.p I got to look this up this is a
new advertiser and I try to be as
welcoming as possible no it's manscaped
all right it's okay manscape everybody
for the Monday morning podcast wait for
the Monday morning podcast comes from
manscape who is number one in Hawaii a
minute this is the first [ __ ] read
and we're missing half of it downtown
comedy club Abu Dhabi to Abu Dhabi Eddie
all right here we go where is it maybe
this one has the entire thing was also
texted to me this is the backup this is
the backup well the [ __ ] is it scrolling
scrolling scrolling dudududu scrolling
scrolling scrolling manscape no this is
the same copier I'm gonna read it man
skate for the Monday morning podcast
comes from manscape who is number one in
men's below the belt grooming manscape
offers precision engineered tools for
manscaping finally finally stop jabbing
at you Bulls there with the right tool
for the right job talk about the fear of
nicking your ball sack while manscaping
do I really need to do that
yeah you got to have a guide the perfect
package 2.0 kit that features the
lawnmower 2.0 with skin-safe technology
this trimmer won't Nick or snag your
nuts it's also 100% waterproof so you
can use it in the shower thank the and I
got nothing after that don't use the
same trimmer on your face that you use
on your balls precision tools for your
family jewels your balls thank you get
20% off free shipping and a free travel
bag with the code birbee you are are at
manscaped comm that's 20% off with bu
our are at checkout and ladies there you
go there's a great thing to get your man
for Father's Day huh
SiC it going down there working your way
through a sea of pubes go to manscaped
manscape comm I don't know what it is /
/ yeah manscape comm 20% off with birth
to check out there you go happy Father's
Day
you'll be trimming your pubes without
nicking your balls and then it'll give
you a [ __ ] BJ oh look who's here butt
out don't do biondi's me undies shaving
your [ __ ] knots to do doo doo bee
undies beyond these the clipper gets
stuck in the ruts you cut yourself once
maybe twice you get rid of your pubes
because you got body lice and you walk
out in the world and jerk off in a park
to a woman with her whole ass out she
kicks the [ __ ] out of you what the [ __ ]
was he supposed to do
no one is banging him he should have
stayed behind the tree
beyond East they are undies these undies
are so soft they make Bob Ross's voice
sound like Gilbert Godfrey the undies
uses the coveted micro moto moto fabric
which is a full three times softer than
cotton not only what you feel like your
loins are being hugged by joy itself
what a beautiful sentence half a
sentence but me Andy
gives you multiple style options for
both men and women why is it always men
and women why can't it be women and men
am i right
is the future feminine lave men can now
try the new boxer brief with fly it's
the same great cuts as boxer briefs just
with a hole now
for number one when you go number one
yeah I do not [ __ ] try to open that
hole when you go number two all right
the undies is also the go-to for the
softest loungewear on the planet hang
out in there super comfy lounge pants
and onesies yes Menzies makes onesies
and their incredible me and Z's has a
great offer for my listeners for any
first-time purchasers when you use when
any but when you when you any me undies
the [ __ ] is going on with the copy here
the undies has great often errs offers
from my listeners for any first-time
purchasers when you blank any me undies
you get 15% off and free shipping get
15% off the most comfortable undies you
will ever put on to get your 15% off
your first pair free shipping and a
hundred percent satisfaction guarantee
go to me undies calm / / that's me
undies calm / better shave you [ __ ]
pubes Jabberwock reviews jjal [ __ ]
dude how about your Boston Bruins
everybody up two games to none making it
look easy against the Carolina
Hurricanes having said that I do not
believe that this series has got to be
as easy as its looked I think that first
game was actually a tough game and I
don't know
so are your yesterday's game that's
that's just look that's just one of
those [ __ ] games
everybody just sucked on Carolina and
they they're gonna shake it off and I
think they going to come up and it's
gonna be a tough game 3 and we can't let
him off the map how funny was [ __ ]
Bergeron it by the way how the [ __ ] did
he not not personally sorry Marchand
when he got the captain on that team to
[ __ ] take a stupid penalty but I
don't understand with his reputation how
he didn't cut calls for a high stick he
[ __ ] had it up against the guys neck
like a sickle and then dragged him down
to the ice and the entire time they're
doing the replay
none of the announcers mentioned his
high stick I don't know but that guy is
so [ __ ] funny when he just said he's
pointing to the ref like he just got
[ __ ] over and they points to the
penalty box and it's the guys chirping
at him he even minds the captaincy
that's on the guys Jersey then kind of
makes a face I could you're their
captain huh I'd hate to see the
assistant captain
another classic Brad Marshawn moment and
I'm gonna tell you why I really like
this year's Boston Bruins is we have a
devastating combination of guys like
Bergeron cray G Marshawn Chara okay to
cut to a certain extent cuz I think he
was backup that last time when we won
the Cup they'd been there they know what
it [ __ ] takes and when you get
veterans like that they they sense the
moments during the game you know when
the push wanted to be but I don't know
what the [ __ ] deal is they just [ __ ]
they just know they just [ __ ] know and
I think we got all these young guys that
are just playing [ __ ] great for us and
having said all of that I am scared
shitless of the San Jose Sharks that is
a loaded team they've been loaded for
years and you got to think one of these
years they're gonna [ __ ] push through
I think they win that series easily
against st. Louis and if we are lucky
enough to get to the finals
but if I honestly if I if I was you know
my heart is picking the Bruins but if I
hadn't really just look at people like I
think the San Jose Sharks are looking
like world beaters and the perennial
favorites are all knocked out this year
so it's anybody's cut and I think all of
that bodes well for your sharks out
there in San Jose San Jose anybody watch
the f1 race
I was so excited that Valtteri Bottas
won another poll because there's really
no racing there's really it's [ __ ]
weird you're just watching these cars go
around the [ __ ] track and this may it
seems like there's like ten pass it's
all about the start of the race
so the [ __ ] race starts Valtteri
Bottas is he's got pole position he's
got the inside on the first [ __ ] turn
I think did he oh maybe he didn't all I
know
no he didn't so the [ __ ] race starts
Lewis Hamilton's in second place gets a
better [ __ ] start bowtie said he had
a problem the clutch he was acting weird
and Lewis Hamilton comes up he's
immediately just wheel to wheel with
them and the first turns a right turn
and Lewis is on the inside Sebastian
Vettel comes screaming up and gets on
the other side a botas like he's gonna
get squeezed now and he goes so late on
the brakes he slams on the brakes and
ends up getting a flat spot on his
[ __ ] front tire that kind of screwed
his race and [ __ ] Lewis Hamilton gets
in first place that I was just I just I
was so psyched my wife was still
sleeping my daughter was still sleeping
and thinking the race came on it like
6:30 in the morning you know like I'm
gonna be able to watch this thing in
real time this is [ __ ] exciting
alright I'd made myself some healthy
[ __ ] pancakes meaning they don't
taste like pancakes at all and I was
sitting there I was enjoying them and
within the first [ __ ] six seconds the
[ __ ] race is over
Lewis Hamilton gets in first place it's
it's over the [ __ ] race is over and
it was so I'm sitting there watching the
race hoping Ferraris gonna do something
impress that the Americans I think we
were in we were in fifth and sixth place
to start the race or 6th and 7th we kind
of were able to hold those positions
mostly for the whole race you know but
it's just like there's no [ __ ]
competition so I actually literally
looked up f1 boring and I went out and I
just looked up some articles and it has
something to do with when they got this
one person was claiming it had to do
with when they got rid of the sick
advertising that they slap put all over
all the cars and those mid-level people
could actually compete and and something
about the aerodynamics where everything
now is so much about the [ __ ]
aerodynamics that if you're in the in
the lead you you make the air so dirty
behind you it's so difficult for someone
to [ __ ] pass you and then also the
cars are wider all you can do like after
Lewis Hamilton gets into the in first
place all you've seen all you're hoping
for now is that he miss manages his
tires they have the wrong [ __ ] tires
on that Mercedes [ __ ] up a pit stop and
it just doesn't happen
having said that I still love this sport
but like they need to do something
because it's just there's the two
Mercedes cars and then there's just it's
just you watching two teammates battle
it out with each other and I have to be
honest I've been watching it since 2015
and that's all I've seen every year they
are Ferraris your Ferraris are really
gonna bugaboo blah blah blah nope now
they just don't I don't know there's
something to like when I go back and I
you know I'm a member there on the f1
website and when you watch those old
race even from like the 90s I mean it's
terrible then you have the camera in the
cockpit it's [ __ ] terrifying you just
looking at the designs and just like
these these guys were [ __ ] lunatics
and that was the height of safety at
that point compared to you know 30 years
before you want to be an incredible book
on Formula One racing read a book it's
called to the limit it was about the
first American to win the f1
championship and just the level of death
that happened spectators and [ __ ] line
oh I've talked about this before but you
got to read the book at one point
somebody gets hit the hood of their car
comes off and spins into the audience
like a [ __ ] Chinese star and
decapitates like four [ __ ] people in
one row I don't know
it's still a great sport but it's also
like the cars are so I don't know what
it is they just there's just no passing
so if you want to get into racing I I
hate to say this because I love f1 I
love the tradition of it and all that
but I got to go MotoGP it's the best
[ __ ] out there the motorcycle racing I
mean granted it's not on [ __ ] Direct
TV anymore so I have to watch it on the
website takes him a long time to upload
the previous race so I'm already a
couple of races behind I finally saw the
the race from the Americas the one in
Austin where I I didn't even I didn't
even hear about it we're [ __ ] Marc
Marquez which is [ __ ] ride-along
turned 12 I believe that's where I was
when I went to the f1 race down there he
just I don't know they said trail
braking whatever the [ __ ] that means and
he just dumped the bike anyways that's
my little [ __ ] thing I still love it
congratulations to the Toronto Raptors
ok year after year they can't get it
done and all of a sudden was is it it's
Leonard the [ __ ] is his first I don't
know [ __ ] up his first name because I
like this guy this guy's an old-school
[ __ ] basketball player Toronto he had
a [ __ ] shot Kylie Kylie Leonard hit
that [ __ ] shot at the buzzer in
Toronto I mean I have to be I don't know
what I don't know what the [ __ ] San
Antonio Spurs were thinking when they
got rid of that guy that guy that guy is
the guy that's the guy you build your
team around he's just like you know I
know I love is when he does [ __ ] he's
not thumping his [ __ ] like that I can't
even watch the [ __ ] NBA that [ __ ]
[ __ ] will you dunk the ball and then
you got to make this mean face it
[ __ ] kids in the crowd like what are
you doing
thumping you [ __ ] chest I would love
to see the amount of times when they
show those [ __ ] highlights of the
game and then they should have the stat
whether his team actually [ __ ] won or
not
I never saw Jordan do that Jordan didn't
do that get the [ __ ] back on defense you
dunk the bed you [ __ ] six foot ten
it's like a nerf rim I don't know but
that's what it is this is this
generation that grew up with [ __ ]
social media and just everything is
about them everything's about them did I
talk about oh did I ever tell you that
[ __ ] story
I told you the story with a lady to ask
me to push her down the hill when I was
in Iceland yeah I already told that
story
[ __ ] weirdest thing ever all right
let's uh let's read let's read some [ __ ]
here oh my god I think I've turned the
corner with my foot I have look at that
the only thing that gave it relief was I
went into the shower and just like
really hot water I don't know why but it
gave it relief whatever happened to that
band that's sang that song mice your sex
is on fire or something like that and
everybody loved him and then they have
one concert and they all got you know
seabirds came in and they [ __ ] on him
and then they're like when I [ __ ]
playin with bird [ __ ] on us and then you
know I never heard from him again your
weight your sex is on fire there's no
way that's the lyric it is your sex is
on fire whether he hey you should go see
a doctor or Kings of Leon how did that
song go sex on fire sounds like she's
got the clap there all right invitations
to malar cook mat malar mal lor see a
deer bill my name is Andrea or is Andrea
or Andrea or Andrea I am an Italian
private chef all right I already love
you based in the island of
Melora Mallorca Spain together with my
girlfriend Rosa Rosa we run a little
business called natural chef Mallorca I
say alright I got to look this up
whatever you're suggesting I'm going if
you're inviting me to go there to a
[ __ ] island off of Spain you kidding
me
Mallorca Spain pronunciation here we go
yep let me hear it
where's the microphone how to pronounce
Matt Lorca Mallorca come on say it say
it say it
Majorca that's it
Majorca oh my you're my your cut is 2lz
Majorca alright alright okay
my orca invitation from my Orca Spain
okay I've been watching your shows for a
year but never had the chance to see you
live oh Jesus I still got the youtubes
on there never got a chance to see lie
well I never even come near you I could
have done these last couple of months in
Europe but all the tickets were sold out
I hope you'll be back soon
also your podcast is great thank you I
listen to it every week even when I work
you say too many [ __ ] so I have to keep
it at low volume since I have clients
with kids but if they let me stay at
their houses alone you are definitely
the guy I listen to all right please
continue with the [ __ ] [ __ ] etc it's
something I would scream sometimes but
luckily there is you I can blame if
someone hears it all right now by the
way let's get to the point I would like
to invite you and your family here to my
Orca if you have a chance to cook you
some great Mediterranean food I know you
are into a more healthy approach to your
diet so I guess you would love it my
Orca is great all year round
obviously the invitation is extended to
you extended to the time it's best for
you and even if you can't make it
since it's quite a long flight and maybe
you'll have already left Europe any time
next year would be great also
I appreciate it appreciate you working I
think you're generally a great person
Jesus Christ I might have to frame that
one well what's the name of your [ __ ]
restaurant Oh natural chef my Orca well
I'll try to get my ass over there man I
absolutely I want to go over there you
know first of all I got to see where the
[ __ ] this is is it is it south my orc
Spain map is it off the west coast
dudududu dudududududu my York banger
paranoid order all right it is it is oh
look at that oh my god it's right in the
middle of are you [ __ ] kidding me
I'll go there you know what my next run
of dates I want to do I would love to do
one in Spain Portugal and then Morocco
and so I I am sold on the [ __ ]
Mediterranean if you're a pasty [ __ ]
your ancestors are all from Northern
Europe like mine you owe it to yourself
to go to the Mediterranean because those
those are the Europeans that know how to
live now this one my okra is also
spelled maj o RCA for some reason we
spell it ma ll or now that makes sense
my Yorker right because in
[Music]
latino-hispanic there whatever the [ __ ]
he's supposed to say that J is a Y right
like it's yo say that or the [ __ ] I'm
talking about right
anyway I'll definitely oh my god I'll
definitely do that you [ __ ] kidding
me I didn't even notice these islands I
always knew Sicily the [ __ ] is this one
called there's one just right out in the
middle of the whole shebang there and I
didn't know that there was a sea within
the Mediterranean Sea the Taira hen E&C
there's another island called course
those Timmy the whoever [ __ ] lives
out there you just that's it you [ __ ]
you you you one you live on an island in
the middle of the Mediterranean Sea
right well the rest of the world is
[ __ ] everything up you sitting there
eating great food oh my god
all right uh yeah I'm in I'm in I'll
figure something out all right
Beastie Boys I'll never be your Beastie
Boy Beastie Boy book hey Bill just a
quick suggestion since you're enjoying
The Beastie Boy book nine year old boys
its Beastie Boy III you know I always
killed me about that band because they
like its Beastie Boy not Beastie Boys
and I always thought and fight for your
right to party this ha ha my bitch-ass
jealous sister Beastie Boys I thought
they said it you should try the audio
version it's amazing each chapter is
read by either the remaining members or
by some very interesting people check it
out audiobooks are very interesting
especially for people who travel a lot I
think you'll enjoy them Cheers from
Brazil I got to tell you I literally
just finished that book last night and
what I loved about the book beyond the
story was amazing
was the time effort and consideration
that was put into that book is is
undeniable like when I was reading it
was all these like beyond their story
they had all these little left turns
that they would take with frozen a
friend of theirs would just like write a
chapter they like at the end of the book
they got some guy just just thrashing
them making fun of the different looks
they've had throughout their their
career it's really really really amazing
and I think also the way that they
handle talking about MCA is just like a
really classy way that they did it yeah
it's a great book I can't say enough
about you know what I'll actually check
that out because I'm sure they have I
would say from
fans all the way to like legendary
rappers I wish I got more into hip-hop
whatever you're supposed to say I just
[ __ ] I just listened to [ __ ] white
boy metal if that's all I did
and like my dad's big band swing records
another great thing about that book
though is the amount of obscure at least
obscure to me musicians and bands that
they brought up and I you know I my
laptop wasn't so filled up I downloaded
a lot of them and I was always envious
of those people who had just [ __ ] get
out of the mainstream and delve into all
these other bands that people weren't
[ __ ] into I just never had the ear
for it I always said like I don't know
whatever that earworm that gets in your
[ __ ] brain at the mall I've never
been able to shed a terminal case of it
so I've listened to some of the
cheesiest [ __ ] music especially now
some of the music I listen to when I was
a kid
so much of it did not age well alright
no meat non tofu burger recommendation
alright Billy Barnes savor I told you I
am a lazy vegetarian because yesterday I
took my lovely wife out for Mother's Day
to one of her favorite restaurants and
they had a ribeye for two oh my god that
this [ __ ] guy and this other dude
ordered there was these two older guys
right we were sitting in a regular table
and over in the corner you know like
what do you call like a bar top table
you know the chairs are really high the
stools but it had like a back on it was
an actual chair and there's something
kind of crammed in the corner and I was
looking at the guys when they showed up
right as you do when you get older my
god I look at him he kept his hair oh
but he's definitely not eating right man
that guy's not eating [ __ ] right
no he's ordering a beer he's still
drinking look at him hanging in there
right I'm just doing that [ __ ] right
dude watching this guy try to get on get
his [ __ ] beer belly behind that he
wasn't even that fat he was like medium
fat it was just so wedged in the corner
this guy tried for like I swear to God a
full 90 seconds to get he tried to get
he had to come off he got on he got off
he was looking at the dimensions of it I
felt like I was watching a silent film
like a Buster Keaton thing the only
thing was missing was like some old lady
playing like the piano and he should
have like lifted up his hat and
scratched his head as he tried to figure
out how to get on there I was like
laughing my ass off and my wife's like
what are you laughing at I'm like I'm
laughing at that [ __ ] pudgy dude
trying to get up on that tall chair but
anyway they ordered this [ __ ] giant
like Fred Flintstone cut I told you I am
a lazy vegetarian we're two out of three
two out of three ain't bad I am two out
of three meals a day I'm gonna eat
vegetarian and then you know the last
meal of day of one of them I'll eat
something am a longtime fan of comedy
relatively long time podcast listener I
was full vegetarian for four years have
been a pescetarian only meat I eat is
fish for about six years just wanted to
throw you a recommendation that a
promise will not disappoint I've tried
every meatless patty from tofu to soy to
tempeh tempeh etc and actually like most
one that is made 100 percent from plants
advertised to taste and quote feel just
like a real burger and actually does
never had one come close what this is a
sentence here but one that is made 100%
from plants advertised to taste and feel
just like a real burger and actually
does never had one come close okay wait
a second I've tried every meatless patty
from tofu to soy to tempeh etc I think
he meant not one I don't know
all right the impossible burger I would
love to hear your meat-eating feedback
giving you a request for intermittent
vegetarianism it can be found at a local
California chain called umami Oh mommy
burger and some other get on it and go
[ __ ] yourself while you're at it
umami you it drives me nuts you know
that Capital One commercial with that
Asian woman gets all
Sassie oh do I hate that commercial why
does it I actually I actually texted
Kevin Shay I go why doesn't she get in
trouble for a appropriation there
cultural appropriation there and I wrote
and yes I am asking you cuz your agent
and he gave me I gotta get him on the
podcast one of the most underrated
[ __ ] comedians out there Kevin Shay
alright Patrice O'Neal Patrice O'Neal
Neil Neil Neil
alright I just wish my mother you know I
had happy Mother's Day I didn't get her
on the phone yesterday it's tough with
all the kids you know what I mean so I
left her a message and I said a really
long text about how she was how great
she was and she's the perfect mom and
all that and she wrote back thanks comma
bill no exclamation point nothing she
just wrote thanks Bill all right Patrice
O'Neal dear Wilford burr
Wilfrid burp I'm not sure if this is how
you asked questions for the MMP but
figured I would try I've been a massive
fan and have been listening to the
podcast and watching special / stand-up
for years keep up the great work thank
you I first heard of Patrice O'Neal
because of you oh that makes me feel
good and I've gone back and watched his
stuff and think it's fantastic yeah
that's the best comedian I ever saw I
saw alive I'm telling you I have also
realized that he had a role in my
personal favorite TV show the American
version of The Office yes he did I find
it amazing that that show had paced so
much attention to the details and get
such a funny person even for one of the
smaller roles I was wondering if you
ever talked to you about his experience
filming that show and what shows that
were / are on the air that you'd like to
be a part of I also suggest if you had
the chance going to Liverpool for the
Champions leagues final coming up June
1st you know what I actually watched
that one where they played against
Barcelona and I actually understand the
scoring now so for all you [ __ ] Yanks
out there with in their regular season
Premier League [ __ ]
whatever there's all these leagues over
there then they have the champions
leagues which I don't I guess the people
with the best [ __ ] records and all
the other leagues play each other and
they play a home at home so there was
one in Barcelona and one in Liverpool so
here's how you can win to advance is you
can either win both games or you can win
one and lose one but have scored more
goals overall and when they add them up
in both contests so what happened in
Game one was barcelona won three to
nothing and then they go to Liverpool to
play so Liverpool is down a game and
down three nothing so the only way that
they can win is they not only do they
have to win the game they got to win the
game by four goals and as we all know
especially Americans you're lucky if
there's four goals combined in a [ __ ]
game forget about one team winning by
four goals well guess what Liverpool did
they got one early I think after
halftime they were up one nil as they
say and then they came out and they
[ __ ] scored two in a row and the
[ __ ] place was going crazy three to
nothing and you could just feel it
Barcelona Tahlia these looks on their
face think we wouldn't know the day they
like I whatever we live in the
Mediterranean we'll go down there we'll
[ __ ] put some olive oil and some [ __ ]
have some great food but [ __ ] English
people they're miserable their weather
sucks this is all they got and they went
on and they scored the fourth [ __ ]
goal to advance a demoralizing defeat
for Barcelona I did see that anyways I
also suggest if you have the chance
going to Liverpool for the Champions
League final coming up June 1st without
most salad they did it without their
best players was incredible although
they play the game at a neutral site I
was in Liverpool for it last year and
even though they lost it lost it was
hands-down the greatest sports
atmosphere I've ever been a part of it
was so much fun and I'm going back this
year hopefully to watch them lift the
trophy all the best to you with
family all right well I got a [ __ ] I
got to check that out let's get back to
the Patrice [ __ ] okay let me see I was
wondering if he ever talked to you about
his experience on on film of the office
yes he did he did he said he was having
a good time but then eventually I think
he got a little frustrated that his role
wasn't bigger and then that he also had
to fly all the way out to LA to deliver
like anywhere from one to ten lines five
lines probably and I think eventually he
just said [ __ ] this which was what I
always loved about him you know cuz that
would have been like uh you know play
and he was just like bill I ain't
getting on some [ __ ] plane to go all
the way the [ __ ] out there for 700 bucks
I'm not doing that and but he did say
that Steve Carell you know everybody
that he worked with was hilarious and he
did like the writing and all of that
type of stuff but he was a big guy and
to get on a [ __ ] plane and fly that
far and sit on set all day that's a
tough thing to ask of a comedian
especially when there was funny is
Patrice and he could make that money in
[ __ ] five minutes doing stand-up in
real time one take was a tall order how
would John Bonham sound today bill that
was another thing to about Patrice was I
thought he was a really really good
actor and oh god yeah I still I said the
amount that I still think about him as
far as just like what he would be saying
about some of the [ __ ] that's going on
today and where his stand-up would be
and how far behind I would be from that
level because you know I don't know if
he's been gone I can't believe it but
he's been gone for almost eight years in
November and I still haven't caught up
to how funny he was in 2011 and I
started a year before him how would John
Bonham sound today bill this guy does
some great videos dissecting music in
this one he quanta sizes John Bonham's
drum tracks from two different Zeppelin
songs
it's remarkable how much quanta sizing
takes away from the real thing oh I
gotta listen to this oh did they did
they I mean even what the way they made
drum so I hate the drum sound of the
[ __ ] 80s oh Jesus how do you guys
find these [ __ ] videos John Bono how
would he sound today well would they
even use them would it be a [ __ ] drum
track over there something that they
sampled alright alright I'm back here
sorry but I accidentally hit stop
instead of pause I just had to get
through this so the Qantas sizing is
something that this guy is claiming took
all the soul out of like live rock
drumming or any drumming words basically
the drum track is put into a computer
and everything's based on the sixteenth
note and it's just all lined up and I
think what he's going to try to say here
is that for those non musicians out
there as far as like the way people play
there's some people that are on the they
on the front of the note there's some
people right on the beat and then some
people play a little behind your is
still on time but some people push it
some people are laid-back and some
people are just like right on and that
is called your feel that's your
personality that's that's the foundation
of you speaking as a musician would be
your feel and then then basically I
don't know it's a million other things
how you hit the drums and what I've
since learned how relaxed you are versus
how tense you are like how it's gonna
come out in all of this [ __ ]
so according to this guy quanta sizing I
imagine makes everybody's feel sort of
the same person so what he's gonna do is
he's gonna play a track of how John
Bonham's drums sound with you know the
original track which is John Bonham's
whole personality the Moody was in
everything playing and then having a
quanta sized way I imagine all
the swing and everything's gonna be
taken away so let's listen to this here
we go come on and now it's not loading
after that [ __ ] incredible intro I
just did you [ __ ] [ __ ]
come on now I gotta hit [ __ ] refresh
yeah yeah I do care I care about
watching another [ __ ] commercial yet
[ __ ] dude remember when there was like
no commercials on these [ __ ] things
now it's like you got to watch like ten
times my you know what I don't do this
anymore
I don't get [ __ ] pissed all right
here we go yeah it's pretty good all
right now I'm gonna [ __ ] talk and I'm
gonna talk and I'm gonna talk
[Music]
okay it's not a consistent tempo years
resume in here I'm gonna go in here I'm
gonna hit alright this video is like ten
[ __ ] minutes long let me let me just
get to the end where you [ __ ] let me
get to the end here I'll do this is this
is a [ __ ] train wreck I really should
oh jesus just [ __ ] hit play you
[ __ ] now play it alright so he
spies basically you can't see what's
gonna you just watch this [ __ ] baby
I'm not gonna try to place how would
John Bonham sound today so basically
what he's lining up but he the quanta
sizes what you just heard and then he
lines up both tracks with each other so
you can see the difference in the sound
waves and all that type of stuff so what
he's basically saying is that when
Bonham was playing he's saying that the
time moves a little bit it's cuz he's
human and there's you know human beings
obviously not perfect and then there's
the emotion the excitement the laid-back
part that you know bands tend to push
when they get to the [ __ ] chorus or
whatever but that's also that sort of
push pull and the expanding and
contracting of the track that's what
makes it alive it's like it's breathing
like your chest opening you know coming
up and coming down and what they do with
like this [ __ ] computer [ __ ] is they
just they level all of that it's like in
Japan where they straighten the [ __ ]
rivers and they take all the beauty out
of it
that's what he's saying I definitely
want to listen to this I don't have the
[ __ ] I don't want to torture you guys
anymore trying to listen to a 10-minute
[ __ ] technical video Jesus Christ if
his time pushes and pulls all right
weird
bedroom noises hi Bill big fan of the
podcast ran into an issue recently and
immediately thought about asking you for
some advice I've notice
this lovely broad while jogging in the
park not so long ago [ __ ] gorgeous
five 210 pounds fit NAT Jesus Christ
were you jerking off to her and she had
her whole ass out doing a [ __ ] and he
was 5 to 110 pounds fit naturally bond
with d-cup real titties this guy's done
his homework
she runs there as well and sometimes
takes a break on one of the benches this
one time I took advantage of that sat
next to her
notice no ring on her finger and started
chatting there you go there you go
turns out she's not only good-looking
but also witty and funny I thought those
things made the same thing just an
all-around great broad long story short
we end up meeting a couple of times and
a [ __ ] few days later and [ __ ] a
few days later enough background now for
the issue she's a devil in bed kinky as
[ __ ] let lets me use all the holes oh
Jesus does great [ __ ] loves sticky
finishes Jesus Christ he's become
[ __ ] skinemax hair I get it
braids my ass hair I got it buddy
anyways um the first time we were
together I thought why the hell are you
single girl you look great
you're a real lady during the day and a
real [ __ ] at night this [ __ ] for this
person trying on purpose to offend
people and then it happened
she got an orgasm her eyes rolled back
and she started making this ridiculously
funny noise with her mouth like a
[ __ ] deflating balloon just a lot
louder I didn't even know humans can
sound like that dude I think you [ __ ]
a mermaid just from the description of
her seriously man I wasn't sure if she
was enjoying herself or having some kind
of seizure it was [ __ ] terrifying
and this happens every single time I
satisfy her she starts screeching like a
leaky sex
all this really kills my enjoyment weird
I know she's [ __ ] hot the screws like
it like a demon but when I hear that
sound my dick just wants to get out I
really [ __ ] hate it but I don't know
how to address it how do you even bring
something like that up dude you don't
you don't can I tell you something buddy
you don't love this woman you you have
you lust after her okay because yet
don't do that to her she can't help it
and that's one of the most sacred
[ __ ] things you see you never ever
ever ever ever [ __ ] do that to a
woman
alright women do it to guys cuz they
don't give a [ __ ] and they play by a
different set of rules they don't give a
[ __ ] you know but you never make fun of
somebody in sex during sex whether you
have the sex you know you never [ __ ]
do that alright you know years later you
want to [ __ ] tell the story by all
means tell the story and even then if I
do that I [ __ ] switch up the details
I say you know I'd say I changed the
timeframe and when it happened don't
don't do that to people
anyway so you sit her down and say goes
what do I sit her down and say We Need
to Talk and the teller she sounds like a
[ __ ] crying rhino she seems to be
totally unaware of the issue or totally
freaked one of the other I thought it
ways to mitigate this and talk to her
and talked her into some role-playing
one night we pretended to be teenagers
[ __ ] in a room this is really getting
weird while her parents now I'm judging
you while the parents are downstairs and
she put a pillow over her face when she
was about to peek the other night we
pretended I'm a kidnapper putting a
sleeping mask over our eyes and gagged
her with her own panties this really
worked out but there's only so many
ideas I have what should I do
many thanks men all right I think the
next role plays what if her mimes what
if we're mimes and we're [ __ ] in the
park I mean I don't know where you go
eventually you're gonna lead to playing
like Anne Frank and you guys are in the
[ __ ] walls and this Nazis in the
living room maybe you got a break
what they're do you got to break up with
there okay what you have here is you you
you have a beautiful woman you got with
her you enjoyed each other you had a
good time but like there's not enough
there for you to look past this thing
that you shouldn't bring up to her and
she's so hot that you're now thinking of
role playing games where you can stuff
something in her mouth dude you're
really bottoming out right now when I
look at this like this is your dick is
keeping you in there all right
and put your brain your heart your soul
everything that you know when you really
connect with somebody it's just not
there so you got to walk away you got to
tell you dicta all right now you you
have a hilarious [ __ ] story just
change up the details wait to you when
you tell it so people don't figure out
it's her but yeah that's it what should
you do I think you should yeah you
should break up with her they'd find
somebody you're truly in love with or
deal with the fact that she [ __ ]
screams like a [ __ ] mermaid like
Daryl Hannah when she says her name and
splash other than that there's nothing
there's nothing you could do yeah I
don't that's [ __ ] hilarious that
she's that hot that you're actually did
she would literally sitting there going
like oh I can't deal with this noise but
she's so hot I still have to [ __ ] her
and you came up with two different ways
let's pretend we're teenagers and we're
for how to find the post to catch a
predator how the [ __ ] can you pitch that
and that went over well is beyond me but
god bless you do good luck but that's a
good problem to have all right but all I
can say you know do whatever the [ __ ]
you want to do there I'm not feeling any
sort of love here did she that you're
into her like that but the only thing
any stresses do not make fun of her okay
that's who she is that's how she's just
you know she's letting it go good for
her god bless her okay God knows she's
[ __ ] treating you right
all right so that's it that's the
podcast oh my god did I [ __ ] art for
half a second I thought I'd plug the
wrong [ __ ] thing and I thought those
are my headphones all right I'm good I
was like ah Jesus I just talked for an
hour and for something [ __ ] minutes
and nobody heard it over there all right
that's the podcast go [ __ ] yourselves
I'll check in on ya on Thursday and go
Bruins